The Joe Rogan experience now when they found that ancient Greek,
uh,
computer thing on what is that called?
Sierra mechanism?
Yes.
Yeah.
Again,
not testifies to a lost navigational skill that we have not taken account up
incredibly complex.
And it took a long time for them to figure out what that even is.
Yeah.
What do they think that is now?
Um,
it,
it tracks the movements of the planets.
It's a,
it's a navigational device.
it,
it's a geared cogged system that allows you to track the passage of time and
figure out where you are.
It's,
it's some kind of navigational devices not fully understood.
And how old is that?
I think that goes back to Greek Times,
I'm guessing here because the Greek times are not of great interest to me,
but I'm thinking around about 500 BC.
So at least 2000 years old.
2000 plus.
And we know that there had to be more than one.
Yeah.
Yes.
It,
you can't,
you can't have something like that without,
without a vast effort behind it.
Human beings.
We're working on creating this geared and cogged machinery,
uh,
that,
that reflected that.
How was that a recreation?
That's a recreation.
Wow.
Did He,
can you buy one of those?
It looks like you buy that dude find bookmark that we need one right there,
right next to the plasta cells.
Sure thing is a,
is a cultural artifact,
which doesn't just appear out of nowhere.
It has,
it has to have a context.
It has to have a background.
And again,
my suggestion would be
perhaps a secret technology.
It's very odd that very few of these have been found.
And it may be that ship owners and navigators in Greek times,
we're extremely careful about who they shared this technology with it.
They may,
it may have been as top secret as,
you know,
nuclear power is in,
in,
in our world today.
Oh,
that makes sense.
But the fact is that then we have to wait.
It exists.
It's real.
It's there.
And then we must consider what's behind it.
What,
what led to that?
Is that just the latest manifestation of something that that goes much more
deeply back into human,
human culture.
And I think that is,
I think,
I suppose my main,
my main message is that we have,
uh,
so far untold backstory that we're concentrating entirely on the front story.
And the backstory is missing,
very largely missing from the picture.
And what I've tried to do is to fill in bits of the backstory.